health so far outweighs all other
blessings of life
that a truly healthy beggar is happier
than a sick king
whoever violated trust once loses it
forever
wealth is like seawater
the more we drink the thirstier we
become
and the same is true of fame
mostly it is loss which teaches us about
the worth of things
we forfeit three-fourths of ourselves in
order to be like other people
from the point of view of youth
life is an endless future
from the point of view of old age
it is a very short past
reading is thinking with someone else's
head
instead of one's own
the first 40 years of life
give us the text
the next 30 supply the commentary on it
[Music]
the clever are not so much looking for
loneliness
as they avoid the fuss created by fools
ordinary people merely think how they
shall spend their time
a man of talent tries to use it
[Music]
each person can be completely himself
only while he is alone
life is a constant process of dying
each person can be listened to
but not everyone is worth talking to
every man takes the limits of his own
field of vision
for the limits of the world
to get married means to have your rights
and double your responsibilities
[Music]
it is better to find your mind in
silence
than in conversation
he who does not like loneliness
does not like freedom
a high degree of intellect
tends to make a man unsocial
living happily
means
living less unhappy
life swings like a pendulum backward and
forward between pain and boredom
if you have reason to suspect that a
person is telling you a lie
look as though you believed every word
he said
this will give him courage to go on
he will become vehement in his
assertions
and in the end betray himself
societability of people is not based on
love for society
but on the fear of loneliness
politeness is to human nature what
warmth is to wax
[Music]
compassion for animals is so closely
related to kindness of character
that it is safe to say that he who is
cruel to animals
cannot be a kind person
hundreds of objects that give people
pleasure
are boring for a big mind
a vain person should know that the good
opinion of others
which he so achieves
is much easier and more true to create
by silence
than by talkativeness
a sense of humor is the only divine
quality of man
[Music]
treat a work of art like a prince
let it speak to you first
you should be very careful not to form a
very favorable opinion about a person at
first acquaintance
otherwise in most cases
you will have to be disappointed
[Music]
he who writes carelessly confesses
thereby at the very outset
that he does not attach much importance
to his own thoughts
fate shuffles the cards
and we play
if we happen to hear how half a dozen
rams scornfully scold an outstanding
person
then we will understand that to value
the opinion of people highly
will be a lot of honor for them
intellect is invisible to the man who
has none
he who has lost all hope
has also lost all fear
a fool chases pleasure
and finds disappointment
a sage only avoids grief
we rarely think about what we have but
we always worry about what we don't have
almost all of our sorrows spring out of
our relations
with other people
such is the lot of great people in the
world
they are only
recognized when they are not alive
[Music]
talent hits a target no one else can hit
genius hits a target no one else can see
[Music]
compassion is the basis of morality
happiness consists in frequent
repetition of pleasure
the person who writes for fools is
always sure of a large audience
[Music]
one should use common words to say
uncommon things
man can do what he wills but he cannot
will what he wills
[Music]
it is difficult to find happiness within
oneself
but it is impossible to find it anywhere
else
religion is the masterpiece of the arts
of animal training
for it trains people as to how they
shall think
great men are like eagles
and build their nest on some lofty
solitude
nine tenths of our happiness depends on
health
people are like watch mechanisms
that start and run without knowing why
[Music]
so the problem is not so much to see
what nobody has yet seen
as to think what nobody has yet thought
concerning that
which everybody sees
no rose without a thorn
but many a thorn without a rose
[Music]
hope is the confusion of the desire for
a thing
with its probability
we can regard our life
as a uselessly disturbing episode in the
blissful repose of nothingness
the safest way of not being very
miserable
is not to expect to be very happy
every parting gives a foretaste of death
every reunion a hint of the resurrection
[Music]
shortness of life so often lamented
may be the best thing about it
change alone is eternal
perpetual
immortal
if we were not all so interested in
ourselves
life would be so uninteresting that none
of us would be able to endure it
[Music]
we seldom think of what we have
but always that of what we lack
faith is like love
it does not let itself
be forced
most of the time
people take advantage of you when saying
you're better at something than they are
[Music]
if they gossip about you it means that
you are enough not only for yourself but
also for others
men are the devils of the earth and the
animals are the tormented souls
after your death
you will be what you were before your
birth
don't tell your friend what your enemy
shouldn't know
the business of the novelist is not to
relate great events
but to make small ones interesting